you see what Trump said in the
deposition this is why people love him
now
familiar with someone by the name of
Natasha stoinoff
smashed her to Oblivion he goes like
this
no
smash her to Oblivion
starting off
so pissed you'll have to give me a
little bit you remember she wrote you
remember she wrote about you a lot when
she worked at People magazine oh I do
remember there was some woman oh
contempt that wrote and then she
a long time later I think she wrote a
wonderful story
and then a long time ago
as I remember it a long time later she
said that I was
aggressive with her
but she wrote the most beautiful story
and then all of a sudden like is it a
year or two years later she comes out
with this phony story that I was I said
well why would she have written such a
good story for people magazines she
wrote a really nice piece I agree is odd
all of a sudden like uh you know
years or months many months later
she came up with this phony charge let's
watch a video and again I apologize for
the technology where you talk about miss
doing allegations then there was a
writer
from People magazine oh boy oh boy
oh it's about to be off the rails on our
first anniversary
the story was beautiful it was beautiful
it was lovely oh boy but last night we
here
that after 12 years this took place 12
years ago this story
a new claim that I made inappropriate
advances
during the interview to this writer
I mean dude playing the crowd so hard
people grabbing [__] while they're
doing oh wow wasn't it part of the story
that appeared 20
or 12 years ago why was it a part of the
story why didn't they make it part of
the story
I was one of the biggest stars on
television yeah and it would have been
one of the biggest stories of the year
um think of it she's doing this story on
Melania who's pregnant at the time
Donald Trump our one year anniversary
and she said I made inappropriate
advances
and by the way the area was a public
area people all over all right let's go
you agree with me that the person you
were just talking about in that video
was Natasha stornov correct yes
are you familiar with a woman by the
name of Jessica Leeds
no I don't think so explain go ahead
does that mean that this refresh your
recollection yeah this woman made up a
story
just like your client made it up yeah
just made up a story
having to do with sitting me in it
sitting next to me in an airplane era
airplane
and I mean I'll have to read this again
but that story
was so false also
but this was I guess making out as
opposed to
what your client said this story was so
false this is a disgrace also and do you
recall speaking about
misleads allegations at campaign events
in 2016. I might have when you said in
that video that misleads would not be
your first here it is
you were referring to her physical looks
correct just the overall not I I look at
her I see her I hear what she says
whatever you wouldn't be a choice of
mine either to be honest with you I hope
you're not insulted I would not under
any circumstances have any interest it's
going keep going I'm honest to what I
say it doesn't mean
yeah the video we just watched watch we
talked about this I just just look you
she's your dog you're a dog you look
like a dog you look a basset hound you
know you look a basset hound and I would
never be into you I don't [__] dogs so
you know
dude that's awesome
this guy
wow what a [__] crit just it's WWE
h
crazy crazy crazy
[Music]